hello welcome to science last week from
science mission I am sadashiva pi and I
am going to discuss for papers here to
in detail and to in brief published in
the week of April 14th let us start this
is an interesting paper from David
Salzer slab demonstrating the presence
of major histocompatibility that is MHC
1 antigens on human neurons they
demonstrate the mechanism by which MHC
could be generated and what might happen
in this scenario David's lab used
various histochemical analysis to
demonstrate conclusively the staining of
human brain neurons with antibodies for
MHC 1 previously there was no evidence
of neuronal MHC expression in the normal
adult human brain but microglia and
endothelium hippocampus in normal and
alzheimers disease patients showed MHC 1
expression here is the representative
figure showing the presence of Kemet see
one in tyrosine hydroxylase positive
neurons of human brain in David's lab
quantitative analysis showed more stain
in the normal brain than the PD brain in
addition mass spectrometric analysis
also revealed MHC peptides in the human
brain neurons data is not shown here
others looked at MSC expression by
interferon gamma immunofluorescence in
human embryonic stem cell derived
dopaminergic neurons after interferon
gamma stimulation showed MHC expression
in neurons and dendrites also interferon
gamma showed dose-dependent increase in
MHC expression in various brain regions
as shown here where does interferon
gamma come from microglia relays
interferon gamma
when treated with neuro melanin and
alpha synuclein as you know activated
microglia has been implicated in
Parkinson's disease control experiments
revealed that lipopolysaccharide and
inflammatory component from
gram-negative bacteria also induced
interferon gamma secretion in primary
microglial culture does interferon gamma
released by activated microglia leads to
expression of MHC 1 on neurons it does
as per the data shown here when the
neurons were treated with media
containing interferon gamma released
from activated microglia after treatment
with neuro melanin alpha-synuclein neuro
melanin plus alpha synuclein nitrated
alpha-synuclein and muted in alpha
synuclein caused increased expression of
MCH one also if neutralizing antibody
for interferon gamma is added to the
culture decreased expression of MHC 1 on
neurons was observed this data is not
shown here these data demonstrate the
expression of MHC 1 on neurons under
various conditions in the absence of
microglia addition of l-dopa which is a
precursor of dopamine and produces neuro
melanin increases expression of MHC 1 in
dopaminergic neurons oh album in which
is a 385 amino acid for and protein can
be cleaved to an eight amino acid
peptide wended dendritic cells and other
antigen presenting cells when the
ovalbumin is added to the culture the
peptide is processed inside the cells
and the MHC one with the peptide it
displayed on the surface peptide with
interferon gamma is also used as control
here
when dopaminergic neurons grown in the
presence of the peptide 41 cytotoxic
cells and interferon-gamma more than
fifty percent of the cells died while
knockout of MHC one protected the cells
indicating that the neuronal cell death
is due to the MHC one expression on the
surface in a similar experiment when
dopaminergic neurons are incubated with
media from activated microglia similar
cell death was seen confirming activated
microglia mediated neuronal cell death
in the presence of t-cells so the
authors conclusively established
expression of MHC on the neuronal
surface under various conditions and
examine the possibility of neuronal cell
death by immune cells next let's look at
another publication this one is from lMC
Dickie slab published in pnas the paper
talks about the mechanism by which
hepatitis C survives in the body the
authors demonstrate that hepatitis C
virus induces mitochondrial fission by
our activation of a protein called drp1
this was demonstrated by the
immunofluorescence analysis of the
mitochondrial fission as shown in this
figure authors also show that drp1 mrna
levels go up after HCV transfection and
HCV gets phosphorylated and moved to the
mitochondria here authors demonstrate
that hcv induced mitophagy that is
mitochondrial fission and movement of
mitochondria to the lysosomes in the
immunofluorescence experiments
mitochondria where labeled and if they
are in
cytosol they will be a law and if they
move into lysosomes during might of Ag
they will turn red as you can see in
this figure not much mitochondria in the
lysosome in control and hence no might
of Ag but HCV infection increases red
indicating mitochondria are in lysosomes
due to my turf AG authors also
demonstrate that drp1 silencing blocks
mitochondrial might of AG as there was
less mitochondria in lysosomes these
result indicate that drp1 mediate
mediates mitophagy what happens if you
inhibit mitochondrial fission as shown
here extracellular white virus particles
tighter was decreased in drp1 silenced
cells indicating the functional role of
mitochondrial fission in hcv secretion
intracellular infectivity showed a
notable increase indicating the
accumulation of mature HCV virions
because of the inhibition of virus
particle secretion silencing drp1 and
mff did not affect HCV replication
however in hcv-infected cells authors
observed an increase in intracellular
HCV RNA levels in drp1 silence cells
reflecting the accumulation of HCV RNA
as a result of inhibition of secretion
interference of mitochondrial fission
negatively affected cellular glycolytic
rates and total cellular ATP pool let's
see we induced aberrant mitochondrial
fission may also contribute in part to
modulate the innate immune response
taken together these results suggest
that hcv induced mitochondrial fission
both effects HCV secretion and
contributes in part to the evasion of
the innate immune system depletion of
drp1 our parking induced robust
cytochrome C release from the
mitochondria and promoted activation of
Casa page 37 followed by subsequent
cleavage of poly adp-ribose polymerase a
casa base substrate induction of
apoptosis was also substantiated by
tunel assay which shows accumulation of
tunel-positive cells together these
results strongly suggest that hcv
mediated induction of mitochondrial
fission and mitophagy although serving
as a quality control mechanism to
eliminate damaged mitochondria also
protects wireless infected hepatocytes
from apoptotic cell death facilitating
persistent viral infection next we will
talk about an interesting paper from
dang Lee's lab published in cell stem
cell the paper talks about human somatic
cell nuclear transfer using adult cells
successful somatic cell nuclear transfer
that is a CNT with human cells has
proved to be challenging to achieve only
fetal or infant scnt has been reported
so far authors generated human embryonic
stem cells via Sen T using dermal
fibroblasts from 35 and 75 year old
males embryonic stem cells expressed
standard stem cell markers genetic
analysis revealed that nuclear DNA
derived from male donor and
mitochondrial DNA
derived from both sides now we can
generate human embryonic stem cells
directly from adults next we will look
into an interesting paper from paola or
Lotus lab published in science Milan is
implicated in complex neuronal function
including learning and cognition and
abnormal myelination is associated with
neurological disorders conductance of
neural signals depending depend on
thickness of the myelin the distribution
of myelinated tracks along the length of
action has been assumed to be uniform
authors looked at the Milan distribution
along single axons in the murine brain
using sophisticated high-throughput
electron microscopy what they found out
was individual neurons have distinct
longitudinal distribution of myelin
neurons in the superficial layers
displayed the most diversified profiles
myelinated segments are interspersed
with long unmyelinated tracks functional
significance of these heterogeneous
profiles of myelination required for the
research but authors proposed that it
may have served the evolutionary
expansion and diversification of the
neocortex by enabling the generation of
different eras of communication
mechanisms and emergence of highly
complex neuronal behaviors thank you for
watching science last week